foreign
[Applause]
guest characters play an important part
in every video game they can either be
good or bad for the game
now since the Tekken 8 trailer there's
been a lot of hype on what new things
this game would bring us and questions
on who harada will put as guests in the
upcoming franchise
so recently we made a survey in a turtle
TV on who you want to see as guest
characters in Tekken 8.
here are according to your votes the top
five guest characters you want to see in
Tekken 8. what's about to happen is
gonna be hard to watch
at number five Akira Yuki
akirayuki is the icon of Virtua Fighter
he's also appeared in other video games
like Dead or Alive and Super Smash Bros
with his fighting style he would fit
perfectly in the Tekken franchise
foreign
[Music]
number four Tifa Lockhart
Tifa is one of the most beloved female
characters in The Final Fantasy series
she has a vigorous combat style fighting
with her fists and probably the most
suitable character in Final Fantasy to
be in Tekken
[Music]
uh so then what can I get you
[Music]
thank you number three cosmicuria
[Music]
cosmicurio also known as juryu or the
dragon of jejima is one of the most
beloved characters in the Yakuza I mean
like a dragon series
[Music]
though he would be a tough one to add
since curio never attacks female
characters
[Music]
number two yujiro hanma
[Music]
the primary antagonist of the entire
Bucky franchise yujiro is a Fierce and
arrogant man and shows no mercy towards
anybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
he also uses various martial arts which
would be interesting to see him matched
against Tekken characters
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
here are some honorable mentions
winner
[Music]
rushing Victory player to win
don't expect me to be a pushover
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at number one girl majima
[Music]
as one of the series more unhinged
characters he's endlessly fun to watch
and even more fun to play as
in the series majima is charismatic and
a commanding man that has gained the
respect of friend info alike often due
to his ferocity and skill and combat
which really makes him the best
character to include in Tekken 8.
some do you agree with our list
comment below on which guest characters
you want to see in Tekken 8.
3 okay
[Music]